Oh
my next tournament going to be yeah it's
going to be no richest actually no logo
Norway chess it will happen here in
Norway in Stavanger I think you knew
about it
yeah no it's going to be fun to play on
my home sort and I'll have a couple of
weeks to prepare for that how are you
doing to prepare for that well I'm going
all over the world until the 17th mate
than which and national holiday and then
after that I'll be home till April is
your name for the tournament obviously I
didn't play my best last year and I'll
try to be extremely strong I think this
6th highest on the ranking list apart
from him there they're all there
well compared to last year we have
kramnik Agrisure and Kurama playing and
those are I mean they are we did the
tough to Spanish yeah yeah it's a
Carioca he needs to to Europe as well he
won the tournament last year the normal
chess enough now he he comes from a long
speckled grouse on the one half on the
one hand I think he's pretty proud of
his streak I think so it's reaching I
think it's reached 15 games now really
with I mean including the Russian team
championship if that's what it told me
15 or 16 to his but on the other hand I
mean he's even though he he's a solid
player he's still place for women in his
probably dissatisfied with just making
gross so you think it's a coincidence
them yeah I think he'll have some
decisive games that no okay thank you
for now thank you for now I'll be